is that for me um is that Kylie store me
a week after the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star confirmed that she and
Travis Scott were taking time apart the
rapper posted two videos to his insta
story featuring their baby girl dancing
to his music and it sounds like Kylie
may be in the background okay so we
can't see Kylie but it definitely sounds
like her let's run that back one more
time now Travis doesn't appear in the
video so this could totally be a clip
Kylie sent him but either way they're
co-parenting earlier this month et
learned that Kylie and Travis decided to
take a break after more than two years
of dating baby a source at the time told
ET the two hadn't been together as a
couple for roughly a month but are on
quote good terms Travis and Kylie
reportedly split briefly in February
after rumors surfaced that he cheated at
the time the rapper's rep denied the
gossip telling ET in a statement quote
it is not true he did not cheat and
that's not getting twisted now a source
tells ET the couple has been hot and
cold since their last breakup and
haven't been able to fully get on the
same page again although they aren't
together now they're both open to
getting back together in the future if
my true fans or want to know personal
following their split Kylie took to
Twitter to tell her fans Travis and I
are on great terms and our main focus
right now is stormy our friendship and
our daughter is priority people say
things all the time and some things I
just think feel like responding to so I
just felt like responding about it
now a source tells ET quote Kylie has
exactly what she's always wanted a child
and to be a young mother although she
hopes things with Travis do work out she
knows she'll be okay if they don't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]